oder was geht da ab ist marx und
herzlich kommen zu dieser runde guetta
und heute haben wir allerdings eine
besondere runde am start ich bin nur mit
franz auf dem server down show dort an
das reh winzer team das es möglich
gemacht hat sehr cool von euch auf jeden
fall wir werden uns jetzt ein kleines
battle liefern wie ihr wisst des franz
unglaublich stark im get down haben
schon ein paar karten ausgewählt
atlantis lsd und mario werden wir
spielen bist du bereit franz allerdings
3 1 2 1 ich war gerade mit ruhm
warst du dir den treuen das konkreter
bekommen allerdings 201 ich bin auf
einer seite direkt runter gefallen noch
runter gefallen du hast du hier oben
erstmal alle geholt oder wie oft ihr
steht darum mit ideen hat insgesamt
schon ab dass 400 bekommt weil wie
gesagt die ersten beiden bringen immer
so 100 fest ja das weiß ich dass die
ersten konz mehr bringen als uns als
andere
wir haben jetzt ganz andere bedingungen
als beim normalen gittern
es heißt wenn eine rasche dann ist
seiner von und wollen wir jeder so wie
er berichtet bis sagen jeder wie er will
ok also wenn ich jetzt denke oh franz
wird mir gefährlich so lieber nicht noch
mehr calls auf der karte 30
dann mache ich das mach ich das so ich
sehe in diesem leaderboard gar nicht
durchführbaren so nahm sie da sind und
kaum erkennt vor du hast schon durch den
anfang an relativ damit gestorben ja
ohne gewinnen ich bin ja ich bin
gespannt ob ich seinen vorsprung
aufholen kann
aber ich finde er ist schon relativ
stark für den anfang so oder hast jetzt
ein paar points verloren wobei es hat
sich einmal vielleicht so 40 oder so hat
jetzt wieder ein bisschen gibt berlins
also eigentlich nicht zufrieden dafür
wie ich jetzt mal obwohl tag wie müsst
wissen leute ich habe ich respekt vor
franziska wer hat der hat was war dann
kein rekord 2400 er hatte ich ebenfalls
also ich hatte einen höheren warte 53
mit denen konnte ich mir gerade mal auf
die führende holz die 132 besser ich bin
eine sekunde vor gestorben ich finde es
irgendwie ausspannt viel spaß
normale bundesjugend wie special er
lässt sie jetzt kommt natürlich auf
geht's los als ob du irgendwo in der
nähe des werde ich jetzt einfach tragen
ich habe schon geschaut gerade auch für
die unternehmen wird stürmen [ __ ]
kleines abschicken
hallo glaubst du ich sehe das nicht mehr
so viele können wir kommen am laufen
sind wie viel hast du dir davon geholt
3 okay das schon extrem gut es war
wirklich kein tagen oder sogar natürlich
erzählt ich dachte so ok
der typ vor sie geraten meinen
hauptspiel köln blöcke mit einem haufen
haut oder alles das war jetzt aber ein
tag dran ich bin in die gleiche richtung
weil sind 34 kommen werke aus als
hättest du überlebt als hättest du
überlebst überlebte mach doch keine
faxen franz du vollidiot eigentlich mehr
sind jetzt machen für mich wenn ich
runter springen würde glaube ich wenn
ich einfach nochmal sterben würde du
machst das wasser meisten für dich
selber würde ich sagen ich bin das
herunter gefallen so diesmal geht
vielleicht woanders hinwollte jetzt
nicht so sagen so von wegen
du kannst nicht aber du kannst nicht
verstehst du
in der mitte sind auch extrem viele
sicht also somit hoben um an ich glaube
du hast jetzt gerade übels aus hast du
überhaupt mit sich führe
aber ich finde muss ja zu sagen
franz ist auch noch einen ticken besser
in pvp als ich also das wird auch noch
mal echt spannende sache ist wenn einer
von uns ein ok bogen hat 91 im prinzip
weniger ist dabei gut war williams zwei
spielen also auf distanz ohne aber ich
denke mal mit dem was wir bekommen
können wir uns alles kaufen ok just me
crazy überholt alles was drunter
gefallen mir nicht mal geschafft aber
ich glaube ich kann die runde vielleicht
noch für mich entscheiden
punktemäßig aber du führst immer noch
beide 1500 coins nach der zweiten runde
und jetzt kommt die entscheidende karte
ist wie mario
wenn wir ein klappt das so gar nichts
gesagt dass sie jetzt hinter mir ist
jetzt ziemlich aus schichten ein
dashboard können
das ist nicht geschafft leute leute es
ist ich finde es fast fast cooler bzw
das ist richtig cool das mal so
abwechslungsreich zu spielen es ist
richtig vettel bleibt man kriegt sich
nicht ganz herunter sondern gehört wird
diese seiten wir sind auch beide
ziemlich konzentriert also der rede
anteil hält sich doch ziemlich gering
aber finde ich gar nicht schlimm
eigentlich außer kraft und franz nike
ein rekord hieß am essent steht 2160
nicht schlecht die sache ist hat
insgesamt schon 360 durch unterkommen
kann ja klar klar das war ja auch ziel
meine taktik so gerade eben war ich ganz
und hat mir dann springe ich jetzt schon
oder springen herunter und bringt mich
um aber dann dachte mir okay jetzt
kriegt halt märkten der consult zu wenn
ich mich wenn ich jetzt unter lampe und
das habe ich es einfach gesagt so ich
glaube ich gar nicht auf den bau bzw auf
den klassischen februar sei es ihr
darauf achten dass wir alles schaffen in
der zeit ja auf jeden fall
ich bin so gespannt franz acht sekunden
zeit haben wir noch höherklassiger
gebracht habe ich mir nie aufbau auf die
greg smith was du hast dir die drecks
mit für eine angel ist es genau die
richtige art ist sie perfekt aber für
ein amt was ich es kein anpassen statt
fünf stellen machen will gibt es
schlicht an schärfe fünf schwert bisher
habe ich vor zwei herzen verloren zwei
herzen durch den drop
5 geht auf papier wieder voll vier nicht
auf einem kanal hochgeladen erwischen
dann stärke 5 erhoben unschärfen fünf
alter richtig gut ja ich hatte gar übels
ist auf meinen schon keine feder fall
mal drauf ist nicht ich entscheide immer
zuerst meine schuhe natürlich meine
stadt und land wegen sinnvoll oder wie
die wegen wasserläufer hast du natürlich
die eigentlich kann ich die angel
faktischer vergessen weil ich werde
sicher nicht so doof sein und noch mal
hingehen ich gedacht jetzt nämlich so
schnell damit angeln kann wo bist du hin
ich will da wo ich runtergefallen ist
immer noch da oben drauf haben du bist
auch nicht wo du lebst runtergefallen
habe ich gesehen ja halbes schwein aber
dein schaden
naja was soll ich sagen ich hab schon
mehr schaden bekommen das für trenker
weil der stadtring dass kinder keine
starke franken kommt ran
hör auf lasst das siehst du ich seh dich
erinnert das versteckspiel ich bin
gerade nach unten du bist runtergefallen
aber nicht nur angekommen da unten bist
du ich bin in eine richtung gelaufen
wir sind vorbei
verdammt was manche sachen wie viele
herzen oder sagst es nicht leicht franz
taktisch am spielen hier ich muss echt
gucken wie ich mich bezüglich der
rationierung eines bestimmten verhalten
express in deutsch
ja er war sehr gut was da nicht zitieren
und jojo ist es spannend ist es spannend
ist der showdown hier fallen so was
gibt's halt in der normalen runde nicht
so ein schauder und mit dem equipment
ist es echt crazy ja ich gerade echt
nicht einfach für 100 kleine angel dazu
gekauft haben ist gut
nachteilig immer komplett weiß was mir
letztes passiert ist okay ich habe
glaube ich einen schwerwiegenden fehler
gemacht da waren damals ein richtiger
lasse sich nur eine angel auf der map
sogar aber nicht im wasser
und ich habe einen bogen geschossen er
hat mich zurück gehandelt und ich habe
mich mit meinem eigenen pfeil getroffen
habe gebrannt und im op bogen was er
mich nach hinten geangelt oder hinter
sich ist nach vorne gelaufen und habe
ich mit meinem eigenen bogen getroffen
weißt du was ich echt vernachlässigt
habe vl walter für mir das nicht dass da
gar kein gegessen doch ich habe schon
viel gehört
ok erste der extra herzlich nicht durch
0 extra herzen was hast du denn
investiert die abstand 90 der röhre
zurzeit 90 level
oh nein
hellwigs oder nein
endlich habe ich den track erhalten noch
nicht zu finden nämlich so dass unsere
deathmatch und 3000 jahre dauert von
aktuellen zeitpunkt wenn ihr echt
gespannt was sie gekauft hast alles ja
wieder eine rüstung so entscheidet ist
hast du eine staffel 4 schenk ja das
schon was unendlichkeit auf dem bock
hast du nichts hast keine pfeile
einsammeln ein fehler
ich dachte das würde nicht so so bogen
bogen lästig werden
unser feind die es tatsächlich geworden
ist und die schöne zeit zu retten eine
20 herzen
20 überhaupt nicht zu haben in der luft
den fall ausgeschlossen
machst du das dann bin ich meine vielen
er nicht dran hier weil ich nicht weiß
ob ich habe acht herzen gehabt hätte ich
mir den bogen gekauft haben ist war der
grund es war mein größter fehler den
bogen gekauft habt weil ich dadurch
durch dieses ständige brennen weil ich
muss meinen fall rationieren ich konnte
dich nicht die ganze zeit brennen lassen
bleibt übels herzen verloren die ganze
zeit bin ich mir direkt welche auf einem
golf-resort egal was sagen das war's für
heute
wir sehen uns einfach nichts mehr wieder
macht's gut